[Music]
veronica is a spanish horror movie
directed by paco plaza
set in june 1991 it tells the story of a
horning and possession brought on by the
use of an ouija board during an eclipse
throughout the movie there are several
callbacks to the real life case in which
the movie is an adaptation of such as
key dates and a police report
in this video i will be discussing some
of the true life events that inspired
the movie as well as explaining what i
take its ending to mean
the movie opens with our protagonist
veronica using an ouija board in an
attempt to summon her deceased father
the ritual is interrupted mid seance and
therefore unable to be completed which
allows a demon to remain in the living
world
throughout the film this spirit haunts
veronica and taunts her family to no end
realizing that she must banish the demon
veronica reenacts the original ritual
and when things go wrong she is murdered
by the monster the police arrive on the
scene to witness the devastation and
thus the famous police report is created
while certain events have been adapted
the police report is real and several
scans are available online to be read in
their full gory detail
known as the velasquez case by spanish
language paranormal sites the real story
differs slightly from the fictional film
the case takes its name from the madrid
neighborhood where a young woman
estefania guaterres lazaro rather than
veronica reportedly performed a seance
at school this similar to the movie the
girl was attempting to reach out to one
of her friend's boyfriends that had
recently passed away during a motorcycle
accident a nun broke ouija board ending
or interrupting the ritual but the group
that participated described seeing a
strange smoke going up through
estefania's mouth and nose following
this estefania would sometimes go into a
rage barking at her brothers she would
also reportedly tell her parents that
she saw evil shadows walking past her
room at night worried sick her parents
took their daughter to see several
doctors but none of them could find
anything physically wrong with her
estefania died but not at home battling
a demon instead she passed away in a
madrid hospital in august 1991. the
police report doesn't really have much
to do with her estherfania's family
didn't get them involved until more than
a year after her death they did however
report hearing a loud noise coming from
an empty porch the door of a perfectly
closed armoire opened in a sudden and
totally unnatural way and a crucified
jesus separated from his cross the later
ghost encounters would receive a slurry
of multiple witnesses the actual basis
for the plot of veronica is little more
than an anecdote though the facts of the
case aren't quite as spectacular as the
events in veronica the police report
contains evocative descriptions calling
it a situation of mystery and rarity the
events were witnessed by three officers
and the chief inspector of the national
police so this goes a long way in
explaining why the velasco case
continues to enjoy so much attention in
spain whilst the ending of veronica is
very clear in the young girl's death the
meaning behind it is completely open to
interpretation personally i view
veronica as a willing participant in her
suicide
realizing that the demon would not leave
her or her family alone until it got
what it wanted she sacrifices herself in
a bid to rid those she cares about from
its presence veronica had a very
unstable life she was practically the
sole carer for her three brothers and
sisters due to the fact that her mother
was so absent in their life because of
the long hours she worked the death of
her father must have had a huge impact
on the girl especially because it
happened at such a young age and the
longing to be reunited with him may have
pushed her final act in the movie we see
that demon finally claim her in the
film's climax but as she had already
severed a main vein the possession will
likely only be that of a cadaver meaning
that the monster is unable to go and
inflict pain on others as it had been
doing earlier in the film with things
like the hot tap and strangulation this
is a courageous move by the girl and we
can take some solace in the fact that we
see a photo reassemble in the movies
closing shot
symbolizing that she has been made whole
again and perhaps has been reunited with
her father once more in the next life
veronica is a brilliant foreign movie
that we are very lucky to have on
netflix if you haven't seen the film
then i definitely recommend that you
check it out while it's not perfect
there is still a lot to enjoy and the
horror fans will find plenty to love
thanks very much for taking the time out
to watch this video i would really
appreciate it if you subscribe to my
channel as i create videos like this
weekly and i'm sure you'll find
something on here that you'll love
if you're interested in more of my
videos then please check out my recent
explanation of the cloverfield paradox
which is linked on my channel thanks
very much for watching my video and i'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you